ein heißer Januar soll es werden
Proteste die das Land noch nicht erlebt
habe so die Ankündigung der
Bauernverbände seit gestern Abend
blockieren Landwirte bundesweit
Autobahnauffahrten ab heute wollen sie
für mehrere Tage den Verkehr len legen
und mit traktorenkonvois durch große
Innenstädte fahren um so gegen
Subventionskürzungen zu protestieren
unterstützung erhalten sie von
Spediteuren die Sorge vor einer
Radikalisierung der Proteste ist groß
rechte Gruppierungen wie der dritte Weg
haben das zu aufgerufen die Aktionen zu
unterstützen der Deutsche Bauernverband
hat deren Teilnahme jedoch für
unerwünscht erklärt wir sind stark genug
auch auf der Grundlage unserer
Verfassung und zu demonstrieren und
unsere Anliegen und die haben wir im
Fokus die Rücknahme der Steuererhöhung
in der Rahmen der Aktionswoche dann zum
Ausdruck zu bringen seit dem letzten
bauernprotest ist die Bundesregierung
bereits zurückgerudert Landwirte bleiben
nun doch von der KF zteuer befreit die
Subventionen für Agrardiesel will die
Ampel aber abschaffen wenn auch nur
schrittweise bevor wir mit dem
nordrinwestfelischen Ministerpräsidenten
über das Thema sprechen schalten wir
erstmal zu zwei Hotspots der heute
gestartet Bauern Protestwoche und zwar
zuerst zu Ina Baltes nach Wachtberg
etwas südlich von Bonn das im
bevölkerungsreichsten Bundesland und
ohnehin ja schon
staugeplagten NRW einer der Schwerpunkte
werden soll was ist denn dort heute zu
ja wir sind hier an dem abfahrtplatz
sozusagen und hier fahren die Traktoren
jetzt los sie sagen es sind ungefähr 100
sie haben sich schon seit einer halben
Stunde hier um das ganze Feld herum
versammelt und fahren jetzt hier los
Richtung Bonn sie wollen da die
Innenstadt blockieren und mehrere
Autobahn Auffahrten wir haben selber
fast gar nicht hier hineschafft weil die
Traktoren natürlich von überall her hier
hingekommen sind Wachtberg das ist eine
Gegend da sind eher kleine Höfe im
Vergleich zum Osten hier sie hat man
natürlich große Angst dass man mit
diesen Betrieben gar nicht mithalten
kann mit diesen großen Betrieben im
Osten und ich habe so das Gefühl dass es
hier gut organisiert ist es sind viele
gekommen sie sind gut organisiert hier
in Wachtberg es sind vor allem junge
Leute gekommen und auch
Handwerksbetriebe wie wir hier sehen die
die Bauern unterstützen wollen in Ihrem
Anliegen es geht gar nicht so sehr das
ist mein Eindruck um diese dieselsubvent
sondern es ist irgendwie so als ob diese
Entscheidung der Bundesregierung jetzt
hier fast so ein fast zum Überlaufen
gebracht hat also man ist wütend auf die
Bundesregierung die man ohnehin
wahrscheinlich nicht gewählt hat es ist
ja eine sehr konservative Gegend und die
Bauern wählen eher konservativ und das
sie hat jetzt das fast zum Überlaufen
gebracht sie haben Agrarreform hinter
sich und sagen jetzt reicht nichts mit
uns es geht gar nicht so sehr um diese
Summe der dieselsubvention sondern sie
wollen sag sag dass sie benachteiligt
sind im Vergleich zu anderen EU-Ländern
und daher sind sie wütend trotzdem
hoffen Sie hier in Wachtberg dass es
friedlich bleibt dass sie wollen sich da
nicht von irgendwelchen anderen
politischen Kräften unterwandern lassen
das ist ihnen wichtig und jetzt fahren
Sie also hier los ein Traktor nach dem
anderen Groß und Klein Richtung
Innenstadt und wer hier in Bonn heute
auf die Straße muss mit dem Auto der
muss viel Zeit mitbringen so also die
aktuelle Lage in nordrinwestfallen dann
schauen wir mal etwas weiter in den
Norden und war zu Bernt Mosebach nach
wberlin in Mecklenburg Vorpommern dort
haben die Bauern angekündigt mehrere
Auffahrten der A24 also der Autobahn
zwischen Berlin und Hamburg zu
blockieren Bernt wie ist dort die
Situation
aktuell ja mittlerweile sind seit 6 Uhr
alle Autobahn Auffahrten in mecklenburg-
Vorpommern blockiert das sind insgesamt
62 Auffahrten von denen geht nichts mehr
los also wir sind hier an der
A24 Richtung Berlin die Auffahrt ist
gesperrt die Auffahrt Richtung Hamburg
ist ebenfalls gesperrt und das geht ja
heute schon seit 6 Uhr zwischen 6R und 9
Uhr finden diese Aktionen statt und man
sieht auch hier dass die Landstraße die
auf die Autobahn führt ebenfalls durch
diese langsam fahrenden provozierend
langsam fahrenden Trecker weiterhin
blockiert wird also das sind schon
erhebliche Verkehrsbehinderungen der
Verkehr hier ist
nicht sehr stark heute morgen aber es
betrifft eben alle Autobahn Abfahrten
und es betrifft auch die Innenstädte in
den Innenstädten der größeren Städte in
in güstro in Neubrandenburg in Schwerin
in Rostock gibt es weiter starke
Behinderungen darüber hinaus und das
sind nicht nur die Landwirte die dort
demonstrieren sondern vor allen Dingen
auch noch andere die sich auf diese
Demonstrationen draufsetzen und sich
dranhängen an diese
Demonstrationen davon sind einige auch
nicht gerade auf dem Boden der
Verfassung und da hat hier der
bauernpräsident der Präsident des
landesbauerverbandes sich klar
distanziert denn natürlich wissen die
Bauern dass die doch relativ gute
zustimmende Stimmung der Bevölkerung für
ihre Anliegen hier möglicherweise kippen
kann wenn sich dann plötzlich andere da
drauf setzen also das G geht heute noch
bis 9 Uhr dann werden sich die Bauern
zurückziehen aber ich habe heute morgen
mit Landwirten gesprochen das ist eine
klare Kampf kampfansage erst wenn alle
Forderungen erfüllt sind werden auch die
Proteste
aufhören und Sie werden das Ganze weiter
für uns beobachten Bern Mosebach und
inina Baltes ganz herzlichen Dank für
diese aktuellen Informationen und Bilder